it's great to go to film school and you
can learn a lot of intellectual
knowledge but learn by doing if you have
a golf ball-sized consciousness when you
read a book you'll have a golf
ball-sized understanding meditate
regularly and then the second thing I do
is drink coffee he's an American
director producer screenwriter and
photographer his films have been known
to disturb offend and mystify audiences
he was described by the Guardian as the
most important director of his era he's
David Lynch and here's my take on his
top ten rules of success rule number
nine is my personal favorite and I'd
love to know which one you guys like the
best and as always guides as you're
watching the videos if you hear
something that really resonates with you
please leave it down the comments below
and put quotes around it to other people
can be inspired as well also as you are
writing something down it's much more
likely to stick in your head to enjoy
the idea comes and you see it and you
hear it and you know it how does it come
it comes like on a TV in your mind you
know there's a line of I've always loved
of limit Cohen he said if I knew where
the good songs came from I would go
there more often absolutely people we
want i we don't do anything without an
idea so there beautiful gift and I
always say you desiring an idea is like
a bait on a hook you can pull them in
and if you catch an idea that you love
that's a beautiful beautiful day and you
write that idea down so you won't forget
it and that idea that you caught might
just be a fragment of the whole whatever
it is you're working on but now you have
even more bait thinking about that small
fragment that little fish will bring in
more and they'll come in in the hook on
and more and more come in and pretty
soon you might have a script or a chair
or a painting or an idea for a painting
but they come as in small more often
than not small fragments I like to think
of it as in the other room
the puzzle is all together but they keep
slipping in just one piece at a time in
the other room over there
[Music]
in a sense David there's always another
room somewhere that's a beautiful thing
to think about let's think about it a
bit now you think about it
and my advice is to do what you truly
believe in don't do something to impress
any studio or some money people it
always seems to backfire as far as I've
seen do what you really truly believe in
and learn by the doing it's great to go
to film school and you can learn a lot
of intellectual knowledge but learn by
doing and now the cost has come down you
can really really go and then you can
see how things go there's lots of film
festivals you can enter into and see if
you can catch some distribution or some
financial help you have a golf
ball-sized consciousness when you read a
book you'll have a golf ball-sized
understanding when you look out a golf
ball-sized awareness and when you wake
up in the morning a golf ball-sized
wakefulness but if you could expand that
consciousness then you read the book
more understanding you look out more
awareness and when you wake up more
wakefulness its consciousness and
there's an ocean of pure vibrant
consciousness inside each one of us and
it's right at the source and base of
mind right at the source of thought and
it's also at the source of all matter I
loved to scripts by a guy named Gregory
Brooker spring of 61 and the falling
rinds of Glen and those those things I
loved yeah and plus and so the idea
there Mary wants you to direct it she
says take a look at this and see if
you're interested in resurrecting it
ranked and you but everybody notes first
of all this is not like anything you've
ever done before right I am
it was he was curious I'm reading the
script and I'm feeling thing and I've
always said that the film is such a
beautiful language it can it can do
abstractions they can do abstractions
and it abstraction are there the
combination of all these different
elements that you have in a film
it can do an abstraction of emotion and
I felt this emotion coming from the
script and that's what I really that's
what lit my fire that emotion of what
the emotion coming from scene from a
word from a look when you read something
we all have the experience we put it in
our mind and those pictures those
initial things are what guide us from
then on and so as this thing you know I
was picturing it at the same time I'm
feeling things and I'm thinking film can
do this and it could be beautiful this
thing about emotion you know it's it's
it's an intuitive thing the the the film
talks to you and the story talks to you
and so it's a little bit action in
reaction you know you you're you're
experimenting as you go to get the thing
to feel correct and and how come it have
to feel correct to me and so you work
and work until til it does feel correct
I think it's very important sometimes to
look at old older work and it can give
you ideas for you know the present work
and or even ideas for the future it's
kind of important to sometimes go back
and I felt that same way about seeing
the films with my son I was glad I went
back and it kind of inspired some things
for the future and it was basically a
good experience I personally I love
restrictions because it forces you to
create you know in this kind of like
boundaries and maybe you think of neat
ideas and with because of these
restrictions it's always in a film you
wish that you could be doing something
else it's just like having a
it becomes you want to escape and I
think it's like this pressure and
responsibility is just a yearning to be
doing doing anything you know when going
anywhere so many times going to the
studio in the morning I wish the driver
would you know become crazy and take me
anywhere
but when you get there you're back in it
and working in spite of the restrictions
this is such a fantastic process and
it's creating and creating is the
coolest thing that we can do for me what
has happened is the heavy you know
weight of anxieties and fears those
things have gotten less and less and
less and for me life has gotten to be
more like a game and the things that
used to you know almost kill me don't
kill me so much and the enjoyment of
doing gets so beautiful and the ideas
are flowing more and more and that the
thrill of it all the thrill of it all I
appreciate people more I see people and
I see their faces and I I feel like I
they seem familiar and I just don't have
so many problems and life gets more and
more beautiful and I still love the same
things you know painting and making
films it just gets better and better
that's my experience leave yourself have
your own oil free out
other things can inspire you but find
your own voice
he threw to that boy don't that he says
little is it never turn down a good idea
that never made a bad idea and true to
the ideas all the way along every
element when you finish a film your job
basically is over and when you you have
a desire to share your work and so you
put it out into the world and you
realize that yes you can help the film
some by giving interviews or you can go
to some places and and have talks but
basically the film is on its own and you
can't tell whether it's going to go good
or going to go bad if it's important
that you believe in your work and and
that's the most important thing
Transcendental Meditation is obviously
the most important thing to do day in
and day out transcending is the key to a
better and better life and this idea is
catching on more and more in the world
the receptivity to Transcendental
Meditation is growing by leaps and
bounds thanks to so many in this room
and someone else others around the world
it's really happening it's built for the
human being and transcending our nervous
system is built to transcend an
experience that unbounded eternal
infinite immortal immutable ocean of
pure consciousness within it's money in
the bank meditate regularly and then the
second thing I do is drink coffee
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because Luke asked me to
so there's a famous entrepreneur that
you want me to profile next leave it
down the comments below and I'll see
what I can do
I'd also love to know what did David say
here that resonated the most to you what
are you going to take from this video
and immediately apply it to your life
your business somehow leave it in the
comments and I'm going to join in the
discussion finally I want to give a
quick shout out to Luke did the same
Luke who requested the video share it to
Luke thank you so much for picking up a
copy of my book your one word and making
that awesome art piece around hustle
which I guess is your one word as well I
really appreciate the support so thank
you guys again for watching I believe in
you I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much love I'll see you soon
I lit up but the cleanup keep coming
we're German what are you doing sorry
what are you doing every phone call
sorry okay now come over here alright
you're in the shot okay you know you
seen this kind of crazy you know many
times tonight we're handling it and you
just hold it like this okay and you guys
just get up and you stand right next to
her
it's like this and anyway I got ya our
clowns are down oh yeah yeah sounds
about it okay you got 30 seconds
this is absolutely unforgivable I don't
care
unforgivable we could have shot this
scene three times
how many minutes will be Justin and
Laura ready on the set in the best she
leans against this column I'm on her and
that's when you get in here with the
monkey all right oh don't thank the door
okay
Christina you're going to shoot yourself
in the crotch assuming is racing into
that chair with the monkey I come off
that chair is empty I come off and I go
over here too Masumi in the monkey okay
okay now when I go over to Masumi in the
monkey you waste into the ship exactly
yes exactly with the reflection of the
light oh so beautiful I remember it now
I need a very microscopic small amount
thick
Eric need to watch a cigarette pack of
matches and the silk we have a mirror
ball I can take that mylar wrap it
around one day your rubbers the rubber
ball better than a disco ball auger and
behind waiting a staircase there's a
staircase right here that goes up which
I did I can't go the photos and a
decision oh I want to see that staircase
so bad man
where's that hammer you've been talking
about not yet sweet there's Jay good
so the only moment of each paw shooting
we're not shooting where's Juliet she's
coming where is Julia she's coming she's
not here
I'll tear this off officer tear the pump
off what about Dominic we wanted a
summer night
why would he be different assuming this
David hi how you doing good
are you ready to work Friday night with
a monkey you see God even you wouldn't
have you been taking drugs on it when I
went in here okay not let's move quick
the drugs
okay we'll start in on meditation really
soon offended if I sort of get the
sticks in the meantime writer and soul
sorry
ah man unbelievable
it has Regan digs mm-hmm
you use the Jeremy Eric
[Applause]